what is this you asked it's totally okay
if you don't know most people have never
seen something so ghoulish it's Dana
prinos attempt at K so I made K so she
wrote like it was a signed confession to
a serial killing
I made K so yes you did you made K so
look like a melted golden retriever I
think we can agree this is not something
you would put inside you know it's
something that would fly out of here
after drinking the water at a Tijuana
hostel I don't think I've ever seen
anything more inedible in my life and I
include prison food seriously no one on
death row would touch this they take the
chair first the picture went viral of
course it would it looks infectious so
how is this homemade it looks like the
leftovers from the all the oil changes
at Jiffy Lube
it looks like a foot spa you might buy
at the chair Nobel gift shop
it's the bronzer runoff from the bikini
contest a fondue pot from Three Mile
Island
I hear Isis is taking credit for it yeah
Dana Perino made queso it's not her
Forte okay so from Perino it's like ab
a-- doing gangster rap a care-bear doing
a lap dance
of course Dana took a picture of this
bucket of hideous bubbling doom and
tweeted it which is basically making
your own kick me sign and taping it to
your back it's gonna live forever yeah
she made that unholy stew then forced it
on her horrified friends to eat I could
say this is one of those occasions when
you're relieved you weren't invited
probably you know who's really grateful
for Dana's case oh yeah this guy at
maroon 5's Adam Levine who is usually
the cheesiest thing on earth not last
night Dana looked at that tattooed
cringe crooning cheese stick of a dork
and said hold my spatula Adam should buy
her dinner for taking the spotlight off
his awful performance just don't let her
cook you know you deserve it I mean look
at that then it looked look at the film
on that it's worth the worse than Birth
of a Nation I had a new recipe yes
off the Internet's yes and they said it
would be like Chili's bar and grill for
the they have great queso there yeah so
I thought I would try it
Chili's was so embarrassed that they had
to go on Twitter and deny any
culpability I was I was trying to be a
good hostess and I attempted to make
queso well you know what
best thing is I had some leftover so I
brought it for everybody here yeah and
we're not having any of it at least for
me okay this is one when most Southwest
Grill brought their case so which of
course is amazing what would did you
make it again enough what did you make
it a game it was the worst game you know
I like football I got but it was hard to
watch now some people said to me oh if
you love defense it was a great game but
even the defense you know I'm looking
for Southwest Grill actual queso they
wait wait is you're supposed to look
like now it's chilly kay anyway about
the football yeah I was looking for some
spectacular moment like a great catch or
a great run or great defensive plays hey
Wow hey baby did you see that there was
no such moment know what it was Larry
you know Emily was very look you were a
professional look NFL cheerleader yes I
don't have a question I just like to see
you for the Oakland Raiders who are now
playing in San Francisco I know it that
bizarre and the question is where will
they play next year yeah well they're
gonna play in separate Isco now yep
they're gonna play in the giant stadium
right where the cities go Giants play
correct so they'll be playing along the
duct like the first second you know that
dugout not dugout they're gonna combine
football and baseball for would that be
great right now at ODOT co stadium they
have the entire time so throughout the
first half of this season it would still
have the dirt from the Oakland Athletics
you know and then it which is over I
don't think San Francisco is ready for a
Raider Nation to take over every year
but go ahead there's anyway hunting last
night yeah and Adam Lee yes that done a
lot of spooky
I couldn't look at the screen when he
took office I couldn't I had to I had
yeah basically like okay me when it's
over and I can look back and I just a
couple months ago
brought up and I said that this was the
worst decision ever and you actually
defended Adam Levine do you feel that
you owe me an apology
I'd like to take this opportunity to
apologize to you I was wrong about Adam
Levine on the Super Bowl halftime show
I thought he'd do better yeah he sounds
great
maybe in a recording studio or on the
radio but he does not sound good live no
he does hichy he was very cheesy he was
very weak and then they brought in the
this other guy who didn't really live up
to the moment and I walked out halfway
through I couldn't get through it he had
me too it was what about his bare
breasts
yeah Janet Jackson that's true that's
true double standard what's the deal cuz
it seemed like he's the guy who hangs
out in front of the mirror a lot just
poses I saw that President Trump said he
wouldn't let Barron play football
which is exactly what Obama mocked when
he said he wouldn't let his kid play I'm
telling you they're more similar than
you think Obama and Trump I think
they're more similar than you think
Wow President Trump was just expressing
and what a lot of parents absolutely
absolutely it's just that I wouldn't
think that the Trump crowd would be glad
to hear that he didn't want his kids to
play like he said it this way you're
wonderful aren't you happy that your
only supporter scandal tasted I wish I
had obtained a Perino type skin I know
your negative press is my good press I
mean you went viral for bad cheese it's
not Brady gonna retire no yeah I
predicted that at New Year's and now I
think I'm wrong also pretty good the
Rams are gonna win yep so two strikes
no you're close you were so much okay so
third one I almost forgot what's that
well you know what I was thinking that
okay here's the best thing about this
whole queso story it's gonna live
forever I made queso fits with any
picture so I thought I'd make you let's
just say we have a pretty good
production staff that you say hey let's
make a t-shirt
[Applause]
anybody at home anybody at once and I
made queso shirt called Dana on her
private line six four six eight seven
nine five and they're like four dollars
and it all goes to charity
is that great I made case of you you can
put this next to any picture and it's it
works because it could be just something
horrible it could be a dog so much
tweeted a picture of a burnt piece of
bread and said I made nachos not
everybody can cook okay know that you
know the best thing is that from now on
the only thing I'll ever be asked to
bring to a party is wine there you go
that's why I win
don't make it what did your husband say
he said it was good that's all he said
Lucas went back for three balls Jenni
Lander said it was good it was good
Maria Nana way she ate it too did they
ever get it at ER